[Music]
[Applause]
is uh
robert lucetic there is oh an old friend
of the show
author of unplayable an inside account
of tiger's most tumultuous season he's a
journalist and uh robert is back on the
program great to see you why are fans so
upset or at least i feel like they are
here in the united states with this live
tour
well i i think uh dp they've that the
pga tour has done a very good job of
turning what is really a commercial
battle
you've got somebody that's that's just
coming after them
commercially and they've turned it into
a morality play uh by saying this money
is saudi money it's dirty money it's uh
and and listen no one is going to be
defending the saudi government
uh and mbs for the things that they've
done but i think the tour is has made a
pr play
and i think a lot of people are happy
the way professional golf is is run now
they watch it they consume it and it
would be very similar to honestly uh
you know the uh
a few years ago when the chinese decided
to buy a lot of big soccer players from
europe and and put these teams together
in this chinese league and they just
they just gave them silly money and of
course a lot of these guys went but they
went to an inferior competition and i
think the fans were against that at the
time and in a lot of ways the fans have
been
molded to uh to to get to a particular
outcome
why is phil mickelson the bad guy
well look i mean phil
you know basically he has had a steady
supply of foot bullets throughout this
entire
uh
past six months
i think that phil has always sort of
thought himself to be the smartest guy
in the room
and
he thought he could work everything and
make it all and by the way it's it's
worked for a lot of years right let's
let's let's acknowledge that he's done a
great job of
uh of creating a brand
but phil nicholson 51 years old is no
longer
frankly you know obviously he had an
amazing
pga last year and became the oldest ever
major champion so there's something to
be said about that but he's no longer
a force in professional golf he's 51
years old and he was given uh let's be
frank a boatload of money and and
depending on who you listen to i believe
it would i do believe it's at least a
hundred million dollars just to sign and
then you play eight weeks and you get
guaranteed money i mean the the
the the real thing about liv is that
people need to stop looking at it like
it makes economic sense it makes no
economic sense
done they're gonna just essentially
throw a billion dollars against the wall
this year and they don't care because
they want to buy a seat at the table
they are positioning themselves not for
this event this week 48 guys that most
of whom you've never heard of
or would care to watch but
they're they're looking at the guys that
are sitting on the sidelines on the pga
tour thinking of themselves i did this
this bottom feeder just made three
million dollars and i couldn't i didn't
make the cut last week and they're gonna
wait for that steady flow of defections
to come from the tour so i think we're
at uh we're at a crossroads right now in
professional golf it's not going to look
the way it's looked up until now
how will the pga tour respond
well
obviously there's going to be some
disciplinary action i believe it's going
to be whether they make it public or not
i've always thought it was it was just
asinine that they don't just make it
public tell people what you know
why you're suspending someone like other
sports do but the pga tour that
they've always hidden behind this idea
that our
our members are above
uh you know they're the best they're
above they're clean they're all the rest
of it and i know that's an image thing
but
what's interesting from today's press
conferences
at the live event in london
is that we now know that a number of
these players have resigned
from the pga tour they've resigned as
members of the pj tour so what are you
going to do
are you going to suspend the guy that's
resigned i don't think so so
i i i believe that uh the lawyers
that uh greg norman and his backers have
uh have employed
and let's not forget by the way arie
fleischer was running that press
conference okay okay
re fleischer i mean my goodness sorry
uh robert let's fast forward 10 years
from now
where are both sides
um
look it really just depends on how big
the investment
is going to be
i believe that the saudis think that
they're in this for the long haul and
that they will ultimately control
the global golf tour
and the pga tour will become a a
secondary tour and that's the battle
we're in right now and i'm not sure that
they're going to lose because dp as you
and i both know money talks and it talks
very loudly with professional golfers
well it didn't talk loud enough for
tiger
didn't talk loud enough for
jack nicklaus
i'm wondering
does everybody have a price tag you know
rory
justin thomas jordan spieth
does everybody have a price tag at you
know when you're in your 20s early 30s
well okay when you're in your 20s
that's a different conversation to have
if you're winning majors you you're
about your legacy as a golfer
when you are in your 40s and you've won
a few majors and you know that you're on
the back nine of your career and
somebody just floats 20 30 40 50 million
dollars guaranteed
a lot of these guys are going to take it
the sergio garcia's the lee westwoods i
mean look at what they all have in
common you know i think dj at 37
is is is the youngest of the of the of
the big names
but a taylor gooch surprised me because
he's a young guy making his way on the
tour pretty successful one on the pga
tour and he took the money so
ultimately the other interesting aspect
of this is that norman is going after
young players out of college
and this has never really been done
pga tour makes them go through the hoops
to get onto the pga tour but from what i
i was told uh one of the young amateurs
was given six million to sign
and then guaranteed 250 thousand dollars
for every event that he played and
though those numbers you add those
numbers up and that is a you know an
excellent year on the pga tour excellent
year for you know somebody that may not
potentially even get on the pga tour so
he's snapping him up and again it all
goes back to the fact that it's silly
money there is you you know people are
always trying to make sense of this well
it's not going to last
okay if somebody says to you you've got
two billion dollars and you must spend
it what are you going to do you're going
to go spend it right so that's what
we're seeing right now and i do believe
this will be the weakest of field of any
live event because i i think that other
players are looking around and saying
well the tour is not going to really do
anything if i'm still going to be able
to play majors
that's very very important for obviously
the younger guys and their legacy
um yeah so they won't get a guy like
rory because rory's got you know two or
three hundred million in the bank uh he
doesn't really need another 100 million
isn't going to make his life
different and he doesn't want to do it
so
you will always have i think guys that
won't do it but it will be interesting
to see what the majors do if the next
week it's the us open we have not heard
anything from the usga about banning any
of these guys and i don't believe we
will i believe that they're going to
play because there's about 12 of them in
the field so
you know do you think the masters is
going to say to a phil mickelson to a
dustin johnson potentially to sergio
garcia hey uh past champ uh no you're
not going to play in this year's masters
i don't see that happening so
qualification for the masters is going
to be an issue but again i think that
we're going to end up in court that's
probably probably soon and a lot of
these questions will be uh will be uh
answered by courts robert great to talk
to you again thanks for your insight you
got it man robert lucetic the author of
unplayable an inside account of tiger's
most tumultuous season